der rote
hund gebrochen erfolg der
ukraine genau vor zwei jahren
hat haben wir in der ukraine den ersten
fall von corvette 19 registriert die
ersten wochen waren sehr schnell aber
wir machen wir standen schulter an
schulter und wir haben das gemeistert
vor kurzem sind wir von einer anderen
krankheit angegriffen vor einer woche um
4 uhr hat russland in unserer heimat
unabhängigen eingedrungen
und schwerer komplexe und als folge
raketenbeschuss panzer und andere
militärtechnik auf unserem boden im in
die ersten tagen waren sehr schwierig
aber wir standen zusammen und wir haben
gesiegt und so gehört mir auch weiter
schulter an schulter stehen die
okkupanten müssen sich dass die taktik
ändern die
raketenangriffe auf die stoffe städter
ist der beweis dafür dass sie mit uns
nichts anfangen können alle linien
wir alle unsere behalten und alle
positionen und die okkupanten
verurteilt der letzten raketenangriffe
auf gier
und andere städte der ukraine hat die ja
luft haben wir
abgewehrt und trotz der heftigen
beschusses konter der feind nichts
erreichen und ihr feind wird will
unserer ort besser zerstören aber der
feind wir nur den boden des schwarzen
meeres sehen
in hagen zum ziel ist mariä himmelfahrt
kathedrale geworden
architektonisches denkmal und seit
kriegs anfang eine unterkunft für
für alle einwohner der stadt aber egal
gläubig oder nicht und jetzt ist diese
kathedrale beschädigte dienst cnet
momentan liegt und sie nutzen das aus
dass der liebe gott und nicht sofort zu
rächen
zur rechenschaft zieht
aber die gottes
serviert den feind verwischen und die
hat natürlich unser kathedrale wieder
aufbauen und wenn unser feind alle
unsere kirchen zerstört
wer der feind
unseren glauben
aufrichtigen glauben an gott und in die
menschen nicht zerstören wir werden hier
das hausener straße jeder staat wieder
aufbauen und wir sagen den russen ihr
müsst jetzt die wir der reparationen und
kontraktion lernen sie werden müssen
alles zurückzahlen war sie uns angetan
haben und
wir natürlich unsere total
helden nicht vergessen
er kommt um uns umzubringen unsere
städte zu zerstören und alles uns zu
nehmen was vor uns steuer ist sie
schalten unserer leute von der
energieversorgung
verpflegung oder
arzneimitteln sie beschießen
linienbusse sie verhindern die
evakuierung der zivilisten sie setzten
gegen uns alle mögliche waffen ein und
jetzt
erzählen sie über ihre
propaganda
sie bereit sind die humanitärer konvois
in die ukraine zu schicken also bitte
nicht vergessen
millionen menschen hassen sie
und menschen in der ukraine bekommen von
uns alles möglich unsere alle unsere
regierung spuren sind den tag unter
einer regierung hat alle notwendigen
programme vor
ausgearbeitet
der ukrainische arbeitnehmer der um den
arbeitsplatz wegen des krieges
umgebracht worden ist jeder arbeitnehmer
die alias arbeitslos ist bekommt 6,5
ohne jegliche vorbedingungen die
vorbedingungen für unsere senioren
garantieren wir vollkommen auszahlung
der renten und zwar um 14 prozent
aufgestockt am ersten märz das geld
fließt bereits in die banken und
die werden die
bereiche die wir bekommen immer mehr
waffen von unseren
partner soll sich auch die freiwilligen
16.000
16.000 haben sich angemeldet und die
ersten ist schon bei uns angekommen und
wir freuen wir uns darauf und sind dass
erfolge siegers wir haben in unserem
land zwei weltkriege durchgemacht
mussten wir haben
hungersnot holocaust und alles mögliche
über erlebt wir haben kein riesengroßes
gelände von organisationen wir haben
keine atomwaffen wir
überschwemmen sind weltmarkt nicht mit
erdöl und erdgas das einzige was wir
haben das ist unser land unsere erde und
das ist gold wert und dafür kämpfen wir
wir haben nichts zu verlieren außer
unsere freiheit und unsere würde
das ist für uns das höchste gut allen
man hat uns mehrmals versuchte
auszulöschen man hat uns mehrmals hier
daher sich geschlagen man man
wolter uns
sturm zu machen aber niemand niemand hat
es geschafft
wir lassen uns nicht
einschüchtern und wenn darauf hoffnung
hegt der hat keine ahnung mit welchem
land er zu tun hat und solche menschen
sind hier im lande
fremd ich sage erst auf russisch gehen
nach hause verteidiger
russischsprachigen in russland und nicht
in der ganzen welt in russland gibt es
viele
russischsprachigen 150 millionen und was
haben wir hier wir haben hier sabine